hello everyone and welcome to opengl
demo part four opengl tutorial part
four on here on uh code tech editorials
and
i'm just gonna have to admit here in
episode four that
i don't know where to take this series
the part of me says oh just teach people
how to make a game but that's not
exactly what opengl is about opengl sure
is
used for games a lot probably mostly but
if you're like
for the context of literally teaching
people
how the opengl library works games are
not really relevant to that it's more
like do you understand the api do you
understand all the things you can do
with it
do you understand how to use all the
features and what now
are you going to abstract their library
into your library and just
do this same thing they're already doing
except with a function in front of it
sort of thing so the problem now
arises for me were i don't exactly know
what to teach yet i was thinking hey
maybe i'll make a little breakout
pong game and just show some features
from opengl
with that or maybe i'll teach you how to
load models
but that's you know that's just the same
thing i've
kind of already showed with these points
except you can add to it or subtract
to it or maybe i should show you more
about shaders maybe we should just go
full on into shaders which is very
relevant to opengl the thing is
there are so many opengl tutorials and
the reason i started doing this one was
because
i put out a poll on both my patreon
patreon and on youtube and asked
what graphics library people wanted to
tutorial on and it was pretty
overwhelmingly
opengl however all right let me let me
just show you some stuff
okay so if you want to know more about
shaders there's this site
thebookofshaders.com which will
take you from you know a pretty basic
start if you go to the home there's all
this stuff about opengl shaders but as
you can see these are not clickable they
haven't finished this they've kind of
left off somewhere
shaders are really really hard to get a
grasp on
that's my personal experience on on them
at least like
i generally understand how they work and
what they do and how they flow
but still every time i go to change or
write a shader
i have to go look up documentation and
that's where the problem really gets
stuck
for me because like i don't i honestly
don't know where to find documentation
about opengl shaders
it's it seems like everybody writes them
completely differently with different
using different features you can't just
find like a of one version fits all for
these shaders it's like okay what
version are you using do you still have
these features should you use this
feature
is there a better way to do this is this
efficient enough it never ends
uh it never ends but here they seem to
stick with
i don't even know what they stick with
actually i don't even know what version
of opengl they're using and none of
their code
do they specify what version of opengl
they're using it's just
well if you're using es we're going to
do a
precision float whatever that that's
that's the only thing they even specify
here
so it's it's not really clear what
version
even these shaders are for and
you know i don't know what it is about
things that annoy me but i have to i
have to like dive in and keep figuring
them out
so at some point on this channel i will
make some
proper shader tutorials not necessarily
for opengl i might move to something
else i might move to like
directx or something i'm not sure but i
just want to show you that this
is a decent resource it just has some
problems but
that's the thing every resource you find
on shaders
has problems i haven't found a good one
ever ever
it just doesn't even do they even exist
and now let's take a peek at this
opengl which is their main site
and you have about you have coding
resources you got the sdk
you got all the documentation like you
can literally go through all this
instead of watching whatever the heck
someone's doing on youtube and you'll
get a better understanding
of jail i think honestly the only thing
that youtube's good for
is walking through step by step for new
users to get a project so i think maybe
doing something like breakout would be
good and just walking through it all
we've kind of got a nice start to
something like that
however opengl is you know there's a lot
about 3d
and if i'm doing something like breakout
3d is going to be on the back burner
i guess i could show you that and that's
another thing about
this like a lot of the cool stuff that
you can do with opengl
actually has nothing to do with opengl
like putting things
into 3d and using a camera and
and all that that's just like a generic
3d thing it doesn't really
matter if you're using opengl or vulkan
or something so i feel like oh
teach three i'll teach 3d for opengl but
or uh
you know the camera stuff but that's not
an opengl thing
that's a 3d camera thing it really has
nothing to do
with opengl other than opengl can make
use of those so like teaching
those parts of a game doesn't fit with
this type of tutorial as i've named it
as i've labeled it like what fits is
literally showing you the api and what
parts the api
do and how to use them and a camera's
not part of that
it's just like all these little features
let's just look at
some documentation here and see if we
can find anything good they do have some
stuff about the opengl shading language
and it looks like it's been somewhat
recently updated with the 4.6
specification which is the last
and well there's a lot here there's a
lot to go through
there's core profiles compatibility
profiles maybe i should talk about those
maybe i should talk about these
different shading language
specifications
i don't know you tell me so this
basically this whole episode for
is a chance for you guys to yell at me
in the comments or talk to me no you
don't yell yelling's
yelling is not recommended and and say
like
this is what i generally have trouble
with in opengl this is what i have
trouble understanding
like you know the the biggest site that
people
go to is what learn opengl.com i think
which is great this is one of the places
i started well i started in school with
the 3d class but i ended up here after a
while to go get further and this has
most of the stuff
but there are definitely some problems
here that are really
i you know really hard to address to be
frank
like the guy who did this site joey he's
done an amazing job he's
really he's changed a lot of people's
lives basically
and how how well this is all done but
i don't you know he has a lot of stuff
but it's just like his interpretation of
kind of what how to use all this stuff
and some of it's
some of it's battle tested battle tested
you know actually using stuff but
a lot of it's not so i feel like you
could get a lot by going through all
this
if you can do that sort of thing but
what what do you guys think should i
should i just go through the features of
opengl and just
one thing at a time talk about them but
then what
basically all i'm going to be doing is
like is this same thing i'm just going
to be making functions abstracting it
you know and that's
that's not really that that fun like uh
let's see i've got some
some things here so i would have like
you know i have a loader here which
loads everything up
and uh you know handles all this stuff
but you know i could add stuff like uh
i don't know we'll change
there's some feature that opengl is
doing like change uh
i don't know let's go find a feature so
basically you can wrap your own
functions around any feature
in opengl once you've got it included
and is that is that word do it
that's that's where i'm at is it worth
just making functions to wrap
stuff and explain it i mean the thing is
it's very application specific
it really depends on what you're doing
like generally yeah you're gonna bind
stuff and upload your things
upload your vertices and all that but it
also depends on your shaders like this
has to match your shader
and that's not really necessarily i mean
that's an opengl thing you need to know
but for me to show you that over and
over and in different ways isn't really
going to help much
you can probably get just as much out of
understanding c
plus and then going to those reference
pages and saying oh i can do that i'll
add that to my
list of supported stuff and i don't know
i i don't know what i don't know where
to take this tutorial honestly i i've
i've dwelled on it i've tried things
i've shot a few tutorials here and there
and i just wasn't happy with them i
didn't think they were good
so i just didn't upload them and uh
this is it unless i get like some
specific comments saying hey i really
always struggled with this i need this
no one seems to teach this or
how do you do this type of flow that's
uh
that's where that's where i'm at i i
don't know what people need to know
although everyone voted for opengl i'm
not sure what you're missing
out from these other tutorials that you
might need from me
so let me know if you want me to make a
game you want to make like a little
breakout game and
and just show off some some of the
features or should i start just stepping
through
the references and showing you how to
use all this stuff
because there's a ton of stuff like look
at all the stuff i know like textures
are really important
and figuring all that out but you know
there's so much here that i'm still
learning all the time like
yeah i've probably figured out a good
half of this or so but there's always
more
and to be perfectly honest i'm never
going to use half this stuff
so in some regards as i'm i'm basically
working on
becoming a game developer and i don't
want to just be pigeonholed into
setting up new projects all the time and
doing little tiny projects and then
abandoning
if i do that i want it to be like a one
shot not a continuous thing
if that makes sense i know this is kind
of a bs episode but
it's honest this is you know this is
from the heart this is what i'm feeling
this is where i'm at this is why it's
taken so long to get
part four going so i would really
appreciate
your feedback on all this stuff thanks
for watching
see you guys in the next one peace out
you